Star Wars spin-off a forgetful fish a
Merc with the mouth this is a different
kind of superhero story a civil war
between superheroes a surgeon with
broken magic hands and teaching English
to aliens 2016 was packed with good
movies and some bad ones really really
bad yeah it got weird here are the top
10 films we can't wait to see in 2017
raise your hand if you need more Keanu
Reeves one-liners in your life you are a
war or do you want to just give me a gun
you better have your hand raised I mean
who doesn't want to see John wick kick
some serious ass in the sequel it's got
more of those nightclub shootouts crazy
car chases a subway fight against rapper
common and even a matrix reunion with
morpheus and his pet pigeon let's just
hope the bad guys learn not to mess with
wix dog this time around I can't sit
through that again that's some sad that
dunk was a final gift from my dying wife
three words gladiator Hulk armor best
buds Thor and Hulk or back from a long
vacay and ready to save the world again
I never wear cut-offs how do I keep
waking up and cutoffs nomu pounds going
in cut-offs coming out yoo-hoo well at
least we hope they're ready seriously
though we can't wait until these two
team up and kick some ass in this
intergalactic buddy superhero movie
hopefully they can get along this time
don't be surprised at the film pulls
from the Planet Hulk storyline meaning
Hulk will battle enemies in a galactic
gladiator ring yeah it's that x 1000 and
after catching that Doctor Strange
post-credit scene we're betting the
sorcerer supreme makes a cameo and this
one as well if you're still on the fence
about this one check out this poster
holy Sh if you like the fifth element
and who doesn't you'll definitely want
to see this one yeah we're a team it's
based off a french comic book and was
director Luc Besson's dream project
before he made the fifth element that
movie had 188 special effects shots and
this one's gonna have a whopping 2734 so
it's gonna look amazing it's gonna have
like 60 different alien species nine of
which we've already seen in a trailer
just kidding that was Rihanna with her
magical hat how many movies can you make
about fast and furious cars seriously
I'm actually wondering better question
why am I making fun of a franchise
that's made over four billion dollars
it's like every two years or so a
producer calls up vin diesel and asks yo
you want to make another fifty million
dollars yeah but this time there's some
added drama between the rock and diesel
or maybe it's just really good marketing
I mean the movie drops on April 14th and
guess what's on April second
WrestleMania 33 you can't trick us guys
Wolverine is back but he's tired he's
old he's in a ton of pain and he
deserves a really strong drink Hugh
Jackman's Logan has one fight left
inside of him and that's good news
because there's a young girl that's just
like him and she needs his help
Professor X joins the road trip because
this movie budgeted for too old and weak
x-men will be honest Logan isn't getting
hired by uber anytime soon but we'll
gladly give them five stars for being a
brutal badass killer oh yeah this one's
rated R so prepare yourself accordingly
they're back and they're not monkeying
around this time no surprises here we
knew war was inevitable between the
humans and apes and this one sounds like
it's going to be an epic one Caesar and
the Apes have suffered incredible losses
and the primates are faced with their
biggest challenge since co-starring with
matt LeBlanc in this movie monkey Woody
Harrelson also joins the franchise as a
colonel fighting for the future of the
planet we're not entirely sure which
side will be rooting for what was the
best part of Batman vs Superman it's
cherry
hmm definitely not him the correct
answer is Wonder Woman let's be honest
doomsday was dominating Batman and
Superman until Diana Prince shota now
she gets her own movie and when beat up
bad guys on the world war one
battlefield good luck guys in addition
to kicking German but on the battlefield
the trailer shows off a whole lot of
Amazonian ass-kicking in Diana's home of
the mascara also slow motion bullet shot
chances are that guy is going to regret
pulling the trigger do me a favor forget
about every other spider-man you've ever
seen but not 70 spider-man he was
freaking awesome
[Music]
truly amazing following that failed TV
series in five sony films spider-man is
now in the hands of Marvel Studios this
time he's fighting off high school
bullies puberty and evil villains and
search for a date to homecoming kidding
if Captain America Civil War is any
indication Tom Holland is going to make
an excellent teenage Peter Parker who is
far from the experienced web slinger of
past films another first on film Spidey
will rock his 1960s style costume
complete with web wings which look
awesome and all but doesn't mean he gets
to hang out with the cool kids this does
not mean you're an Avenger case you were
wondering oh just a few years ago the
guardians of the galaxy were cielo
celebrities of the Marvel Universe but
now they might be in higher demand in
those a list Avengers Showtime a-holes
no Marvel movie surprise us more than
this one back in 2014 and we can't wait
to see the group back in action
star-lord Gamora Drax rocket and Groot
are all back actually group is a baby
now I repeat Vin Diesel is voicing a
baby tree and it's cute try again come
cut mm-hmm oh good told you he was cute
plus there's this huge alien creature
some cool weapons and a guaranteed a
plus soundtrack oh and we'll also meets
our Lord's dead ego the Living Planet
played by none other than Kurt Russell
not sure how that whole thing works we
still don't know its official title but
it's officially number 1 on our list the
force awakens left us with the
cliffhanger literally well they were on
a cliff at least we don't know a whole
lot of details about this movie but a
few things are guaranteed Rey and Finn
will be back Luke Skywalker will have
some actual dialogue and kylo Ren has a
new outlook on life following his time
on
hover boss at Starkiller base I really
learned a lot and people are gonna love
the new me seriously though we all know
this one's gonna kick ass unless they
throw in a young Anakin flashback I
don't like sand its course rough and
irritating and it gets everywhere please
don't do that Disney will have to wait
until December 2017 to find out so what
did you think of our list anything that
we missed hit us up in the comments and
let us know and if you want to stay up
to date with all of our entertainment
videos be sure to subscribe to gamespot
universe on youtube it's gamespot's
permanent home for TV movies and comics
as of January third subscribe now so you
never miss a video